[Musique]
cadets
bienvenue au newseum un musée dédié au
premier amendement de la constitution
américaine qui interdit d'adopter des
lois contre la liberté d'expression et
la liberté de la presse
c'est un hommage à l'histoire du
journalisme aux états unis un
journalisme de plus en plus malmenée
dans l'air de donald trump le premier
amendement nous donne une liberté
d'expression presque sans limites dans
ce contexte n'importe qui que publier
n'importe quoi il ya donc beaucoup de
source d'information crédible mais aussi
de la désinformation
c'est ici que jesse mccarthy enseigne
aux élèves du secondaire un court plutôt
particulier un cours qui a pour but de
démystifier les fausses nouvelles
comment les reconnaître et comment s'en
méfier mais au fait qu'est-ce qu'une
fausse nouvelle
car la ligne est parfois mince tellement
certaines semblent réelles lorsque vous
ne pouvez pas vérifier l'authenticité
des faits ça veut dire qu'ils sont
inventés que ce sont des mensonges et
les réseaux sociaux sont devenus un
pipeline privilégié pour le partage de
ces nouvelles technologies est un
amplificateur incroyable qui attire
l'attention surtout il y à 50 ans
lorsque vous vouliez partager une
histoire vous deviez découper des
articles de journaux et les envoyer par
la poste
aujourd'hui vous publiez votre histoire
surtout facebook et tous ceux qui vous
suivent le découvre aussi tôt mais
comment discerner les vrais des fausses
nouvelles
cela a l'air si simple et pourtant
c'est là que les vérificateurs de fait
les facs checkers entrent en jeu dans le
petit bureau de politifact à washington
on trouve de véritables fouineur qui
analyse les déclarations faites par les
politiciens
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que depuis l'avènement de donald trump
ils en ont plein les bras il a tendance
à répéter des choses inexactes comme les
etats unis sont le pays le plus taxé au
monde
c'est fait l'enquète sur la collusion
avec la russie est inventé ce n'est pas
le cas politifact se dit non partisan
l'organisation est financée par des dons
d'entreprises médiatiques de bourse de
fondations et des revenus de la
publicité
nous nous donnons pas notre opinion on
prend plutôt le parti de la justice et
de la vérité
ils ont créé une échelle de vérification
qui va de vrai jusqu'à un pantalon en
feu pour un mensonge qui n'a aucun sens
en passant par à moitié vrai ou à moitié
faux c'est un processus très minutieux
éhontée panel se réunit analyse la
position du journaliste et prend une
décision achats dans la classe de jesse
les jeunes tentent de repérer les
fausses nouvelles
en utilisant justement la vérification
de fait c'est aussi vérifier la
provenance de la source d'information
car avec les nouvelles technologies il y
a beaucoup de journalisme citoyen la
jeune avital est ravi du cours mais
elles pensent que ce sera de plus en
plus difficile de discerner le faux du
vrai les forces nouvelles ne sont pas
simplement un problème pour les
journalistes les policiers ou les
enseignants c'est un problème de société
nous devons travailler tous ensemble
pour les enrayer de façon à nous assurer
de vivre dans un environnement où
l'information est crédible et juste
dans les musées en général on expose ce
qui a existé et même ceux qui n'existent
plus le journalisme sera-t-il ranger un
jour aux côtés des dinosaures l'être
humain un désir inné de s'informer quand
on manque de nouvelles on veut en avoir
plus c'est peut-être pour cela que
fausses nouvelles sont si attirante mais
je ne crois pas que l'information telle
que présentée dans ce musée va
disparaître mauvaise passe pour le
journalisme peut-être le futur
c'est cette génération numérique peut
être mieux équipés pour contrer les
fausses nouvelles
un espoir pour que ces témoignages de
plusieurs siècles d'histoire du
journalisme ne soit pas juste des
reliques passé
[Musique]
et